welcome to this video a new part of the
series about basic end games and end
game theory yeah we now moved to King
and pawn and games and we start with the
very basic ones we're just one King
through a side and one pawn is on the
board let's start with a simple case
sometimes the pawn is just promoting of
course here the C pawn is White's trump
card and if it is White's to move
I should probably set it like that then
white is just Jack promoting to the
Queen and wins however if it is blacks
to move in this position like is in time
to catch the pawn yeah is it necessary
to look at all the single moves in this
line and calculate this before and in
fact it is not because here we learn one
of the basic rules of those endgame the
rule of the square you can draw a square
like this from this pawn and if the
black King here the defendant King is
able to reach the square with his with
him to move then he's just in time to
catch the pawn let's make some judging
lots of those end games a little bit
easier because you just see okay I'm
entering the square and it's done so
black to move enters the square and and
draws just like that however it still
makes sense to only apply that rule in
those in this pure form let's say when
there is nothing on the board if there
are other factors on the board then
definitely it
needs to be checked if there is some
something else going on for example if
we alter this position slightly like
here with the porn suddenly appearing
only six it's a whole different thing
we'd like to move here is this said
already let's make sure it is with black
to Moo fear he can enter the square but
unfortunately not this square because
his own pawn is blocking the way this
kind of things can always happen and
there should be taken into account now
you can even complicate this situation a
little bit if you alter it like that
it's a bit more tricky let's say it's
White's move here the rule of the square
here is a little bit twisted here white
can win you can also win in a different
way but one way to win it's like that is
six black takes c5 at first we see okay
black can enter and we get the same
thing as before black cannot go this way
all the way to c8 to stop the pawn
nevertheless it's a very useful rule it
only should be yeah he was with a little
bit of caution if there are other
factors on the board like those
additional powers or something like that
it is some an entirely different matter
if the defending king is is in front of
the attacking pawn or very close to that
let's look at a typical position there
he will see a typical position where the
defending King is in front of the
attacking pawn black is some blocking
the white pawn on the on the back rank
yeah how is this position to be assessed
it all depends on the right to move man
nedly should out of this you need to to
get get a view like this of the board
it's all about who's right to move it is
if it is white then he has nothing
better then Jack advancing the pawn and
after King ed Stanley King e6 it's
unfortunately a stalemate
why truth cannot win it's because black
has to the opposition this opposing
situation with the Kings if it is blacks
to move however I can change that here
black really only has King yet if he
goes to c8 we just will promote the pawn
after King ed we have e seven advancing
to the seventh rank without a check King
f7 the only move King D seven and we are
going to get the pawn promoted on the
six rank it's all about the right to
move I mean with the pawn on the sixth
rank with the pawn on the fifth rank
it's a little bit more complicated here
we have a typical situation with the
pawn on the fifth rank the pawn on the
fifth rank it's all about the key
squares what are key squares yeah key
squares squares that if the White King
here the attacking King is able to to
get to them it will be a win no matter
whose move it is this is very important
the key squares for this pawn are the
ones on the seventh rank and those three
squares on the six rank so we have a
little rectangle of pawns here an offer
of a pair of squares there are the key
squares yeah let's look at this to
really understand what this means
it is not mattering really whose move it
is once the White King gets to one of
those grass you win in this specific
position it is wide smooth and this
means that the only way to win eeeh is
King e6 as we need to stay in the
winning zone King e6 yeah we have the
opposition now the black king needs to
move and then we step to the other side
and here we see that the white pawn will
promote this is also the reason why in
the initial position if we go back where
those squares of course our key squares
once you reach this you have the control
over the squares that let the pawn
promote we should definitely check what
happens if it is not why to move with
King e6 but black to move let's change
that here and we let black move
if King d6 we can start to just move the
pawn because we reach the already known
winning position with the pawn on the
six rank after King 8e 719 F 727 we will
promote what about this remember the key
squares those squares we need to stay
there and King the 7 and it's clear that
we need to stay there because we cover
all the crucial squares to get the pawn
promoted we just need to get to one of
those squares to win this also means
that a number of other positions can be
easily assess let's say for example we
we change this position a little bit
with y to move we know that these two
squares are one our key squares so we
need to go there to win both win so
this is the easiest but also this would
win YouTube this move sequence on the
other hand if we go back and we look at
this with black to move we can easily
deduce what move black needs to play
let's check this that's a change this
black also knows that he needs to
prevent white from going to the key
squares so those two squares need to be
controlled by the king we can go here to
do that or we can go here to do that in
this case it really doesn't matter as we
need to control those two squares but
this is probably the way to go because
you also take the opposition it's a
little bit simpler for the defender to
UM to remember those squares are the key
squares that's the absolutely paramount
thing to remember here black needs to
prevent white um going there white wants
to go down okay let's now alter this a
little bit okay
now we have the G pawn instead of one of
the central pawns it's a cheap on that's
a little bit different and the b-pawn so
a mirror-image B and G pawn so the
knight pawns a little bit different what
is identical of courses it's about the
key squares what is on one of those key
squares so he should win and in fact he
does win however there is a little
there's a little problem here in this
position if white and I should
definitely him and this editing mode if
it's white to move he should be aware
that only with
age six he can force a win why is that
king f6 it's not throwing throwing the
win away but after King h7 the problem
is that what you want to do here is king
f7 and now push the pawn however
stalemate that's very embarrassing the
problem is that we are at the edge of
the board and black if you want cannot
play King - I ate yeah there is no I
fire so white needs to be cautious and
not go for that the winning idea is to
go to h6
it's a little bit counterintuitive but
it's the only way to win here after King
f8 we go to h7 and this thing is
promoting after h8 we and just push the
pawn and now force the promotion
it's about this stale metric that one XI
one should should know about because it
can easily happen that you play
especially if if it's a situation where
you don't have any time on the clock
that you quickly play King f6 because it
looks more normal to do to go towards
the center of the board however only
King aged six is the most most
straightforward way to win here let's
now look at pawns on the fourth rank
yeah the typical position the pawn is on
the fourth rank yeah how to assess it
it's again about key squares the key
squares for pawn on the fourth rank this
these three how does this unfold it's
all about whose side to move it is and I
definitely should do this again I keep
keep this both how often on setup mode
yeah it's all about who's move it is if
we assume that it's White's move
let's say after king e5 king e7 black
manages to keep the opposition and
prevent white from reaching one of those
three key squares however if it is black
to move let's switch that if it is black
to move then he needs to go to one of
those squares and allows the White King
to go to one of the critical key squares
and now white is winning the the main
connection to the position with pawns on
the fifth-ranked is is that white now
can easily force a situation where he
has one of the key squares of the pawn
on the fifth-ranked simply because here
he is if you remember the key squares he
is on one of them so he can just push
the pawn and win the game it's all about
the right to move if white can go to one
of those he will win if not it's a draw
black must keep the opposition to two
and prevent white from going to the key
squares let's now look at some examples
that show this principle in full effect
let's look at this position it is why to
move and again I forgot about that it's
white to move what about this is this a
draw always white losing yeah it's all
about the key squares again if we
remember it's a little bit tricky
because we looked at it from the white
side remember that these three are the
key squares black needs to get his King
to one of those squares and he will win
the game promote the pawn and win yeah
so how does white need to defend blacks
idea is clearly to go here or go here so
we need to react accordingly the only
way to draw here is to move King to d1
yeah it's very important to note that
king d2 is not working as after king d4
black gets the opposition and after King
here necessary otherwise black will
occupy this like place King c4 for the
opposition and he will get to one of the
key squares after this we have managed
and will win the game by promoting the
pawn we go back to the initial position
if white goes kingi - it's very
important now that black finds the right
move the only move now to win is King a
form for the opposition King D to Katie
for King Z - what can never ever go here
because black gets to one of the key
squares king c2 and Kings afford we have
the same position as before with black
getting to one of his squares this
leaves white with king d1 very important
now if black guy was king before we play
King D - and you make sure that he can
not go to one of those squares here here
and again now White has got the
opposition and controls the key squares
after King d1 in the neutral position
black can try kingi for yeah setting up
a last last try
yeah what should Y do now if white now
goes to D - again we have forgotten
about the opposition and will lose
teenager would be a huge mistake we need
to be we need to make sure that after
King D four we play King D to the right
move therefore is King C to King etude
Ross as well but King C to us a little
bit more thematic now black will go here
and after King D 2 we again have the
position that we desire if black tries
to push the pawn now you can make no
progress whatsoever King C 2 C 3 and
only now we need to be cautious of
course we must make sure that we now
make the right King if we go to the 1
black gets the opposition and will
promote the pawn we need to remember
from we need to remember the first
position that we looked at on the 6 rank
it's all about the right to move King C
1 is the right way to go after King D 3
we play King D 1 for the opposition
check and only stalemate stalemate as
possible this was a little bit more
complicated way or complicated position
to look at this kind of key squares and
the opposition that is now look an
example where the pawn is only on the
3rd rank what are the key squares now
comparable with the pawn on the 4th rank
it's all about those 3 squares this is
where white wants to be with white to
move we have a clear path to that King C
to g7 King b3 q6
King before yeah we're just about to go
there but black is quick enough to
prevent us from going there immediately
but after king c4 of course only King c4
we will be able to get the opposition
and get to one of the key squares King
the six King bee five mission
accomplished
but how do we win now like place King c7
the next move of course is of utmost
importance should we now place C for or
should we play king c5 the best move of
course is king c5 what we need to get to
us we need to get to those squares
because those are the critical squares
the key squares for the pawn being on
the fourth rank we need to conquer one
of those squares so king c5 is the is
the key move c4 would only draw then we
don't manage to get where we want to be
black now needs to move to the side and
here and now here we go
we now occupied one of the key squares
for the pawn on the fourth-ranked
this means once we are there we can
start to advance C form King be seven c5
yeah if the pawn is on the fifth rank
those are the key squares and we are
there so we can push the pawn c5 King c8
and now King c6 getting the opposition
and now we promote the pawn note that
it is very very common that you don't
push the pawn first but you need to use
the king to gain the space with those
maneuvers with the opposition to get to
the key squares and only then you can
really push the pawn it is almost always
bad to move the point first and then go
with the King as you need the King in
front of the pawn like this to get to
the key squares that is now look at ya a
special special case with the King and
pawn against the lone king the side
pawns H pawn and a pawn yeah a typical
example white as the extra a pawn can
you win the simple answer is no
absolutely never if the defending King
is ahead of the pawn in front of the
palm you can never win simply because
there are the same eight motifs let's
say white to move the best one can do is
something like that stalemate and it's a
stalemate
black just needs to get to yeah to the
edge of the Bob basically to that the
corner to block the pawn to draw very
very simple in fact there are even
drawing positions where the king is not
in the corner let's look at a very
well-known type of position like that
here it all looks nice for white you
have the a pawn and the black king is
not in the corner but with black to move
black place king c5 and what he does is
trap the White King on the edge of the
board yeah white only has this move and
then black plays King a6 yeah and how
are you ever going to make progress
there if white plays King a5 black can
easily reach the drawing position that
we have seen before so
and there is really no point in allowing
that y-term must play king a7 or push
the pawn after king a7 black just keeps
this side or position here and make sure
that white can make no progress
whatsoever so maybe here a5 should be
tried and again just king c7 if white
now does this we again we reach the
corner so King a7 King c8 and it would
just be a row King d6 corner a6 and we
trap the king this can be can be done
for quite a while and at the end
why does Stanley basically still mating
himself it's just a draw and a very very
common theme in in those those end games
with the H pond or the a pole let's look
at some other cases of those type of
pawns yeah what about this position can
black reach the corner white to move
this win because he is quick enough he
reaches one of the two critical squares
for the H pawn and black is simply too
late
white will promote
the H porn is notoriously tricky let's
look at a little bit a little bit it's a
little bit more complicated way just a
moment
yeah what about this this looks very
easily winning for white two points
isn't as simple it's not that simple
stalemate stalemate
yep those simple moves don't do it we
really don't have any choice
okay a five black only has King g7 and
yeah how do we win now if we know our
King opponent games we will quickly see
that check after this we get to a
position where wide wins and we promote
our pawn a different example yeah let's
look at this position that's why to move
it looks very nice we have two pawns but
can we win and how the first move is
pretty clear we need to play King e6
here protecting our pawn if Black gets
to take the pawn and virgin returned to
b7 He will draw very easily because we
don't get to the critical squares for
the b-pawn on the fifth rank yeah black
now plays King d8 how do how do we
continue now yeah it's very simple in
one way but looking at it a little bit
more detail reveals that there are some
tricks
you cannot go cn8 because of stalemate
this means we have to give up the pawn
now okay but how exactly King d5 aki-nee
five
the right move is king d5 yeah
black now takes the pawn if he is not
taking the pawn let's say he goes here
then the win is easily achieved Jack he
just gets to one of the key squares and
win the game
black mistake here I mean he mistake
yeah how to continue now if we go king
c5 he will go king c7 for the opposition
and we don't we are not able to make any
progress now so b6 must be the move yeah
and what no King d8 King c8 what are we
doing after King d8 how do we win yeah
it's again the opposition doing the
trick
King c8 king c6 and king p8 and b7 and
we will promote of course if black goes
to see it right away
king c6 is the key move to help us
advance and promote the pawn yeah it is
it is tricky but if you know the idea is
about the key squares and the opposition
you will work out of those things
relatively easily with a little bit of
time on your clock okay
let's look at something a little bit
more tricky here white defense against
two pawns a double pawn yeah it's a very
important to know that those two bonds
are big difference to just one point
because black always in this case it's
black has reserved move with the second
pawn the behind pawn let's say this
means me very often can gain the
opposition which is not possible in in
other situations without the pawn
let's say for example white plays King
f2 King e4 yeah this is a very easy draw
if there was just one F pawn Jack but
with two F points we will get to this
situation without this pawn black has
nothing better Stanley then the chip
then stalemate but with the F pawn we
just check play a 5 and the White King
needs to give up the decisive square so
that we can promote yeah a very very
useful thing to know it's a big
difference
with two pawns even if they're doubled
okay
the situation with double points can be
much more complicated let's look at the
most complicated example now of this
video guides why to move in this
position and in fact white can win here
with King f1 key for Kimi to King d4
black is just in time to protect his
pawn but now the GG pawns I set into
motion
if black just loses the pawn he will
also lose the game as we had seen in the
earlier example the double pawn will
provide a win so he must keep the e pawn
as long as possible however after g5 he
now must
leave the protection because he needs to
take care about the pawn take care of
the pond
if white now is careless and takes only
three black of course well we'll just
wrong by King f5 we will not be able to
get in front of the pawn anymore and
black draws easily so what do we need to
do we need to play g4 first making sure
that those squares are covered
after g4 black has nothing better than
King e6 and now white grabs the pawn now
we basically get the situation from the
position before with two G pawns we win
no matter what
Jack yeah and we have the typical
situation with them
with the auto g4 pawn Jack stalemate
it's just like this it with the pawn
after the G 15 g 8 g 7 we will win yeah
it's the jack slightly tricky but we
know that at the end algae pond will
promote let's go all the way back to the
start of all this king of one really
looks like a total totally a normal move
but it's also the only move that wins if
white plays d4 then King c4 is drawing
km1k d3 threatening King G 2 so white
must go Keaney one and now King if all
the big difference is that now after
this we don't have we are not able to
get to this situation where we get the
pass to g5 and G
the only move that we can try now is g5
and after King f5 black will take the
pawn and of course draws this easily
yeah this is a video of about 34 minutes
and if you have no prior knowledge of
King and pawn and games you will have
learned quite a lot here I believe it's
a very good idea to watch this more than
once if really lots of concepts here you
are new to you and also it's it's an
excellent idea to practice those simple
positions against against the friend or
against an engine maybe even an engine
is a is a good is a better way to do it
because the engine any computer will
defend perfectly in those positions it
can simply calculate till the end and if
you practice this sufficiently you will
get to a point where you play the simple
endings here just those King two kings
and the pawn perfectly stuff like that
with more pawns of course it's a bit
more difficult but if you know the
basics behind behind them you have
excellent chances to find the right
solution given enough time yeah I hope
you enjoyed this first video on King and
pawn end games there will be many more
to come
thanks for watching